بالفعل لابد من التوقف عند التباين ما بين
التصريحات الاوكرانيه والروسيه حول بدء
الهجوم من عدم حيث قالت موسكو بان الوضع
اصبح صعبا في العمليه العسكريه على لسان
بسكوب المتحدث الرسمي باسم الكرملين كما
ان بريجوجن اكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه بدات
عملياتها المضاده ان كان في باخموت واشار
الى سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه بالفعل على
مناطق في اجنحه المدينه كما ان التقرير
اليومي للمواقع العسكريه الرسميه اشارت
الى سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا حول
باقمت من الناحيه الشماليه الغربيه حول
بلده بغداد على عده كيلومترات ايضا
المناطق الشماليه الغربيه من المقاطعه
بشكل عام نتحدث عن مارن كاف ديفيكا
اوغلادار تشهد معارك ضاريه صباح اليوم تم
اسقاط اربعه صواريخ هايمرز جنوب اوكرانيا
حول اوغلادار كما ان المناطق الاخرى مثل
مدينه دانيتك وضواحيها تشهد ارتفاع بوتيره
القصف الاوكراني كنا نتحدث عن 50 اقل من
مئه او مئه وعده ضربات صواريخ او قذائف
اليوم نتحدث عن المئات 3400 عادت الذخيره
الى ايدي القوات الاوكرانيه وباتت تقصف
بشكل يومي دون توقف الحديث عن تسعه اصابات
قتيل واحد خلال الاربعه وعشرين ساعه من
المدنيين داخل المدينه صباح اليوم عشرات
القذائف والصواريخ ايضا خلفت قتيل اضافي
وليست هناك اي معلومات عن الاصابات الوضع
بالفعل يشير الى ارتفاع بوتيره الاعمال
العسكريه على كل المحاور كما ان المحور
الاخر وهو الجنوب الاوكراني خرسون وزبروجه
يشهد يعني تحليق
الجو الاوكراني اليوم هناك ايضا معلومات
عن اسقاط طائره من طراز سوق 25 طائره
اوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه تحشد على
اطراف المقاطعتين تريد الوصول الى مواقع
الجيش الروسي ان كان في خرسون خلف النهر
وان كان في زاباروجي من اجل اعاده السيطره
على المحطه النوويه
هي المحور الاكثر اثاره تقول قوات فاجنر
على لسان انهم يتقدمون وقاموا قوسين او
ادنى من السيطره الكامله الحديث عن اقل من
كيلومتر لاكمال السيطره في العمق الغربي
لكن القوات الاوكرانيه تتوسع في الاجنحه
وفي محيط المدينه في مناطق مختلفه
المعارك بالفعل محتدي مع جميع المحاور من
ايام القادمه ستظهر لنا المزيد من
التفاصيل
ان الجيش الاوكرانيه قد حصل على ما
وعده به الغرب من اسلحه وذخيره ومعدات لكن
ماذا عن فاجنر هل حصلت على ما وعدها به
الجيش الروسي
هذه اشاره مهمه احمد ان
بريجوجن وعد بالانسحاب او تسليم المواقع
التي سيطر عليها في باقمت في حال لم تقدم
له الدفاع الروسيه الذخيره المطلوبه في
العاشر من هذا الشهر اي قبل يومين لكن
اليوم نرى بان قوات فاجنر تواصل
التقدم وتواصل القتال في معارك في مدينه
باقمت وتقول بانها حصلت على جزء بسيط وما
زال بريغوجين ينتقد الدفاع الروسيه ويقول
ان ما نسبه 10% فقط قد وصل الى ايدي
المقاتلين وانه يكمل العمليه العسكريه من
اجل روسيا وليس من اجل الدفاع الروسيه
هناك ايضا صراع داخلي ما بين قوات فاجنر
وما بين الدفاع الروسيه لكن هناك اتفاق
على ان هذه العمليه يعني بمضمونها
واهدافها التي يريد ان يحققها الروسيه في
مصلحه امن روسيا القومي